I've always wanted to pee standing up I
think this is gonna be dumb I'm so
excited
very annoying not being able to just pee
standing up because I like efficiency
I've wanted this my whole life if my
boyfriend had to live one day with a
vagina where he had to sit down he
wouldn't go anywhere I sort of pee
standing up because you're in a squat
position because you don't want to touch
the toilet but I don't need a workout
when I'm peeing how many times I've been
on a road trip or a guy friend has like
piss in a bottle we have to hold it pee
standing up
next thing you know lady president
[Music]
brilliant marketing because this says
stand up and take control which is
something I'll say to myself from now on
when I stand up and pee in the shower
this is very like malleable that's
strange I don't want to do I can tell
you this right now I don't want this
[Music]
[Music]
this was been great it really was I'm
disappointed in myself that I get up so
bad in the beginning but once I got it
going I was very happy I hated it
I also feel like there needed to be like
an instructions manual hey don't feel
like a man I'm still confused as to why
guys say they don't need toilet paper
when they pee there's still a little
dribble that I had to like deal with
around here in no way would I have been
comfortable just like tucking this back
into my pants couldn't pee at first
because you're so have lovingly used to
sitting when you pee like when I sit
that is pee time so I had to sit for a
second and then stand up and pee and I
kind of missed sitting down I feel like
there's this kind of piece that you have
when you're sitting down and pee oh I
also realized I'm a little less like
upset with guys when they pee on the
toilet seat because I realize it is
actually kind of a difficult thing the
pee went everywhere I'm all about this I
think it's just fantastic
standing next to people I feel like it
would be a little weird he just wouldn't
be able to pee I could pee in a urinal
no problem can't get it all stared at
anyway there's a sense of community
though right now you think about girls
getting to become better friend I think
it's no they totally check each other
out I'm so tempted right now so just
stop it I'm not looking I'm just epic
don't look at me but I peed on myself
first like life first you pee on
yourself and then you figure it out